serious question grammarians what's the
difference between me
and you
uh well in order to get i mean i don't
mean that you know in a snarky way i i
mean that in like a conceptual way
what's the difference uh in terms of
these two pronouns what separates them
well one's about me and one's about you
but that seems kind of like a
pretty easy distinction it's right there
on the on the face of it right um
english like other languages has this
thing that grammarians call person
obviously we all know what a person is
it's a human being but person as a
grammatical concept
is a way of distinguishing between me
you
and everybody else
in fact we we have special terms
for this
so
any group containing
me
is the first person
any group containing
you is the second person and everybody
else falls into the third
person
so whenever i talk about you know third
person singular or first person plural
all i'm really doing is going back to
these columns of am i involved are you
involved or is everybody else involved
right so both me
and
us or i and we
are first-person pronouns
uh because they're about me or a group
that contains me
likewise you
is the second person that's that's kind
of it it's both singular and plural
everybody else that's he
she
they
them
everybody
it
nothing
everything that is neither me nor you
falls into the everybody else third
person category
so let's say you were giving someone
advice in a kind of a sideways way like
one ought
not
to place one's hands
on a hot stove
uh the the temptation might be in some
cases you might forget what pronoun you
started out with one is a third person
pronoun
uh and and the temptation might
sometimes be you know you forget about
it it sounds like you're saying a piece
of advice one ought not
to place
your
hands
on a hot stove
well you know i mean this is still not a
good idea to put your hands on a hot
stove but you have to remember
which what you're what you're trying to
connect here this is a third person
pronoun and this is a second
person pronoun
and the two of them do not match up they
do not as we say in grammar agree
sad face
so what you what you need to take care
to do is to make sure that if you're
taught if you start off talking about
one even if you're being kind of silly
and pompous you got to stick with one if
you start out talking about you
you got to stick
with you
or i guess i could have changed this
back to one but i wanted to pop with the
with the pig
because if you don't do this then you
run the risk of
being confusing and unclear so you have
to make sure that if you start off using
one grammatical person you have to
maintain use of that grammatical person
for as long as you're talking about
the the same the same notion the same
idea the same person
i used to take harmony singing classes
at the old town school of folk music in
chicago and i had this instructor who
said that the best way to sing harmony
was to remember to stay in your lane
and i think that's a that's a good way
to conceive of how to
think about um grammatical person is if
you start in one lane
don't cross over by the end of the
sentence begin
begin your sentence in the same lane as
you started
you can learn anything
dave it out